some vegas residents have made the
switch to solar power
and couldn't be happier but you have to
choose the company you work with wisely
here's why one local family chose triple
a solar
my first impression was solar certified
when anybody mentions it to me it's john
and how efficient he is
ben and i decided that it was time to
look into
the solar on the roof and i made
a few phone calls i looked on the
internet and
had different companies come to the
house
and then we had made the best decision
and that was to
have triple a certified install you know
our panels
first thing we wanted was somebody that
was here located and established in las
vegas we did not want a company
and there's numerous of companies over
the years that come in
do the job go back to their state
could be colorado arizona california and
when you do have an issue or a problem
you can't get
them to come out immediately to solve
the problem in the meantime
you have panels that are shut down and
you're not generating any energy so
what's going to happen is you're going
to end up seeing
an electrophile i was able to contact
john
i have his number in my cell phone i can
contact him
anytime and the first thing he picks up
the phone and says hey mrs horgan what's
going on
you know and then he carries it through
from there
[Music]
it's expense at the beginning but it's
paying off at the end
our regular statement for the month of
september of
2018 was 293.35
for the month of september one year
later
in 2019 having the panels on the roof
our payment was 11.2 cents for that
month can beat it
for every month you know paying uh eight
to ten dollars a month instead of maybe
two
three hundred dollars a month where the
timids have been over 100 degrees
for the last nine weeks two months
when you think about triple a certified
solar what's the first thing that comes
to mind
the panels you know and john's service
john's service
yeah my my thing is when that when you
say it i can vision john
you know and he's been in our home and
we i don't have my phone with me but he
put a
uh a system on the phone it's called um
i think it's called sensor and um
that device is an app that's on my phone
and what it does
is it picks up every item that is
plugged in or turned on in the house
so i can do a comparable to nevada
energy and just do a little
protection for myself to make sure that
if nevada energy says i you i use this
much or generated that much i can
cross-reference it to the phone and say
okay
they're within pennies it's okay i'll
allow it
more information call 702-331-1511 or
visit
aaacertifiedsolar.com
they have a special offer for you
experience their diy design studio
and get one thousand dollars off las
vegas now we'll be right back